>>> THIS JUST IN, OMAR JIMENEZ
IS LOOK INTO THIS.
AND THE NYPD IS NOT ACTIVELY
INVESTIGATING SEAN "DIDDY"
COMBS.
ACCORDING TO THE SOURCES, THIS
AFTER THE R & B SINGER CASEY
VENTURA HAS FILED A LAWSUIT
AGAINST HER.
AND THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM
ARE TRULY SHOCKING.
SHE WAS HIS GIRLFRIEND AND SHE
SAYS IN A LAWSUIT THAT COMBS
REPEATEDLY ABUSED HER AND BEAT
HER WHEN SHE TRIED TO LEAVE HIM,
AND FORCIBLY HAVING HER HAVE SEX
WITH OTHER MEAN, AND LET TO HIS
LIFE FOR
ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE
EXTREMELY SHOCKING.
AND JOEY, THIS IS EXTREMELY
SHOCKING, WITH SEAN COMBS AND
THE NAMES, P.-DIDDY, PUFFY, AND
HE IS AN ICON IN THE BUSINESS,
BUT THIS IS CIVIL AND NOT
CRIMINAL AT THIS POINT, RIGHT?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
SARA, WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
EXPLOSIVE ALLEGATIONS WITHIN THE
COMPLAINT, AND TO BE CLEAR, IT
IS A CIVIL LAWSUIT WHICH LAYS
OUT CHAPTER AND VERSE, AND WHAT
SHE IS CAMING ABOUT HIS CONDUCT
AND SO THIS IS FILED IN SOUTHERN
DISTRICT COURT OF AND LEADS TO
DAMAGES, MONETARY DAMAGES IF IT
IS PROVEN.
THAT IS DISTINGUISHABLE IF IT
WERE A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
WHERE IT WOULD RELATE TO LIFE OR
LIBERTY INTEREST, AND THAT IS
ABOUT JAIL.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT JAIL, BUT
CIVIL.
SO INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, THE
ALLEGATIONS CONTAINED RELATE A
LOT TO MISCONDUCT WHICH COULD BE
DEEMED CRIMINAL IF IT WERE IN
THAT COURT.
>> THE A GAGS, IF THEY WERE
ALLEGED WOULD BE ILLEGAL.
BUT THE NYPD IS NOT
INVESTIGATING THIS, AND THAT
WOULD INDICATE, WHAT?
IT HAS NOT BEEN FILED OR SHE HAS
NOT GONE TO THE NYPD WITHOUT A
CASE.
>> WELL, THE WHETHER THERE IS NO
STATUTE OF LIMITATION, AND NO
TIME LIMIT, BUT SHE DIDN'T GO TO
THE PROSECUTORS OR TIME REPORTS,
BUT THAT IS BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T
BELIEVE IT WAS SAFE FOR HER TO
DO SO, ACCORDING TO HER, BUT THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE NOT BEING
INVESTIGATED BY THE NW, C.
WHY DO I SAY THAT?
FEDERAL, AND THE FED AS ARE
INDICATED IN THE COMPLAINT.
>> BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO STATE TO
STATE, BECAUSE THEN IT IS
INTRASTATE, AND YOU TAUGHT ME
THAT.
SO WHAT ARE THE ALLEGATIONS SHE
IS ALLEGING?
>> NUMEROUS.
WHAT HAPPENS IS WHEN YOU FILE A
COMPLAINT, YOU PUT WHAT IS
CALLED THE CAUSES OF ACTION.
AND THE CAUSES OF ACTION RELATE
TO WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS
OF THE SEX TRAFFICKING IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS WHETHER
IT WERE MIAMI OR CALIFORNIA OR
IN NEW YORK CAKING MISVEBTURE RA
AND SO THERE ARE EIGHT IN TOTE
OF ISSUES RELATING TO NEW YORK
AND CALIFORNIA AS WELL TO
BUTTRESS WHAT THE COMPLAINTS ARE
IN THE COMPLAINT.
>> SO THE DEFENSE IN THIS, HE IS
GOING TO RESPOND TO ALL OF THIS
IN COURT?
>> WITHOUT QUESTION.
SARA, GREAT POINT.
THESE ARE ALLEGATIONS, AND RIGHT
NOW, VEHEMENT DENIALS INDICATING
THIS IS A MONEY GRAB, AND
INDICATING SOME BOOK COMING OUT,
AND IT IS BLACKMAIL, AND
BRIBERY, AND I DID NOT DO THIS,
AND HE IS ET ENTITLED TO THE DAY
IN COURT, AND PROCESS TO WHERE
THERE IS INFORMATION ON THIS,
AND A NUMBER OF BEING ASKED
QUESTIONS UNDER OATH AND
ULTIMATELY A TRIAL OR